okay now before i do it on the board
i want you to think about it there are
just like with question four
there's two completely different ways
you could approach it
so i want you i'll give you a couple of
minutes to have a go on this
at your own right um don't look at the
person next to you
for the purpose of trying to get a
different answer see if
doing it independently you get a
different approach because i can see
two um completely different approaches
which would both work just fine
just like here but i'll let you try and
work out which one you would pick
now this is really interesting oh
because i've seen
do you remember i said to you there's
more than one way to solve this
okay and i have seen plenty of different
ways around the room okay
regardless of which way you go about it
okay
all of you have you've gotten down to a
final line like this
okay now some of you for instance i've
seen you say
okay lines are working n equals
and now you get a number now for
instance
one of the answers that i have seen is n
equals five i've seen that answer a
couple of times around the room
okay now here's the great thing about
equations okay
there's never any doubt you never have
to be unsure whether you have the answer
or not because
if you have got the right answer if it's
the solution
you can take it back to where you
started and you can plug it in and you
can see if the key unlocks
right so it's a little bit like you know
you're sifting through this pile of keys
and you're like ah
i found it okay well you don't need to
guess whether you found the right key
you just stick it in the door and see if
it opens okay so watch
i'll take n equals five sorry i still
want this color and i'll pop it up here
in the left hand side okay
watch what happens i'm going to get i'll
actually say
lhs the left hand side okay hold stay
with me
stay with me i'm gonna put in
five times three now i'm substituting in
five everywhere i see n so i see an n so
i'm gonna write five
minus one okay order of operations i've
got times here
and subtraction which one do i do first
times
times exactly right so i'm going to get
15 minus 1.
15 minus 1 is 8. 14.
5 times 14 if i'm doing it right i think
that's 17.
right now what was i expecting i was
expecting 80
and i didn't get 80. i'll tell you what
that means it means
n equals 5 is not the solution right it
means i took the key
i took the key and i wiggled around and
it didn't open
right now i can try another number i can
try n equals eight
yes all right i'll chuck it in i'll go
five
three times eight minus one again i'll
do the multiplication
first that's going to be three times
eight is 24.
take away one twenty four take away one
is just twenty dollars
you told me to put in eight so i put in
eight there you did
wait no isn't that five times three and
then you go five times
yeah look at the brackets look at the
brackets you've got to know your order
operations really well
yeah okay so you've got to do what's in
the brackets
first okay i'm not finished yet let's
let's have a look
five times 23 i think that's 115.
it's still not the answer i was
expecting i told you
all right so what is the real answer
history i'll show you 5.6
now
let's give this go now the way that i've
seen
a lot of people have been doing it is
you're very good at expanding brackets
so we take this thing and we expand it
all right so if i get rid of the
brackets
okay now i'm going to get 5 times 3m
that's 15n okay then i've got to do 5
times
the minus 1. so i get minus 5.
is that okay okay good now
what do i do to this now i'm in the same
position i was over here
okay we saw that it was better to
subtract things first so i'm going to
give that a go
oh it's a fraction 5 over 2
15 n equals now if i what do i do to
both sides here
take away the fives now i've got a minus
five here
right maybe maybe i'll write this
to get the opposite of subtraction i
have to add
yeah oh yeah that's what i want
okay can you see that right so the fives
on this side are going to cancel which
leaves me that 15 n
and you're going to get 85 on that side
okay now i just want the n on its own so
i'll divide by 50.
are we finished no we can do it better
than this can't we what can we do to
this
i can simplify how will i do it
the way i'm going to do is i see i can
divide the top and bottom by
five that's the common factor okay now
it's easy to do the bottom
that's three top's a bit harder it's 17.
17 over three do they have a common
factor
five one the the highest common factor
they have is just one the reason why i
know is because both of them
seventeen and three they're both prime
numbers no factors except for one in
themselves
so you're done n equals 17
on three that's the answer okay
now i can try it out by putting it back
in here
and it'll work i'll get 80. come here
okay now last thing before i let you go
okay because this is the hardest kind of
question you're gonna look at so is this
sexy
this is yeah i said there was a
different way to do it there was not
just this way
there's another way and i think it's
better yeah the first step i had was i
expanded these brackets that's how i got
to this line
that's all right thanks sir thank you
you're welcome oh it's 5.6 that's the
last thing
it's not 5.6 it's not if you click the
sd thing it becomes
five points yeah no it's not it is it's
not
no you know why i know because if you're
dividing by three
oh there's 5.6 i just made it like one
ah but it's not
it'll be five point seven if you went to
one decimal place
five two over three so five and two
thirds i think is what you need to say
which is very different from five point
six it says one
over one eight are you looking at the
others
pretty sure you're looking at another
question yeah you are
65 40 right sixty
oh sixty yeah it says
five five and two thirds
well done okay now when you guys are
ready i'll show you the fastest way to
do it
okay now the reason why this
was it'll get you the right answer but
it's not as good
is because when you expand you make
numbers bigger
you're multiplying things you've got
five times three five times negative one
and that's why you end up with these
numbers okay
there's a much quicker way to do this
okay instead of
multiplying through i'm going to divide
now the reason why dividing is a better
way
is because look at these numbers here 5
and 80 right 80 is divisible by 5.
how can you tell this divisible by 5.
it ends in a zero exactly right any
number that ends in a zero
or a five is divisible by five so
instead of multiplying out i'm going to
divide
right watch what happens i divide the
left hand side you just get
what's in the brackets what is 80
divided by 5.
well you told me 85 divided by 5 is 17.
this is 5 less so it's
16. all right now what
i need to add one to both sides because
i've got to subtract one there
so you add one to both sides
okay so now i have 3n equals 17 and then
you just divide
it's much quicker the numbers are
smaller it's a better way to do it
okay um just like here you can see
there's often one
method that's clearly faster than the
other and in the same way
this method's faster because your
numbers are smaller yeah it's not a
curiosity if you're like five
seven in the test would that be right or
wrong wrong
why the way that i would say that 5.7 is
right is i would
ask you to tell me this to one decimal
place
and that would be 5.7 to one decimal
place but it's not 5.7
why well 5.7 right
that's 5 and 7 tenths whereas this
answer
is five and two-thirds now i mean
don't worry about the fives for a second
you're telling me that seven-tenths
equals two-thirds
i mean you can believe that if you want
just don't do my accounts for me because
i wouldn't trust you with my money
okay so 5.7 is not the answer
if you approximate it would be but
nowhere were we asked to approximate
okay